we're told to consider this matrix
transformation or this is a matrix that
you can use represents a transformation
on the entire coordinate plane
and then they tell us that the
transformation is performed on the
following rectangle so this is the
rectangle before the transformation
and they say what is the area of the
image of the rectangle under this
transformation so the image of the
rectangle is what the rectangle becomes
after the transformation so pause this
video and see if you can answer that
before we work through it on our own
all right so the main thing to realize
is if we have a matrix transformation or
a transformation matrix like this if we
take the absolute value of its
determinant
that value tells us how much we that
transformation scales up areas of
figures so let's just do that let's
evaluate the absolute value of the
determinant here so
the absolute value of the determinant
would be the absolute value of five
times eight
five
times eight
minus nine times four
nine times four remember for a two by
two matrix the determinant is just this
times this minus
this times that
and so that's going to be the absolute
value of
40
minus 36 which is just the absolute
value of 4 which is just going to be
equal to 4.
so this tells us that this
transformation will scale up area
by a factor of 4. so what's the area
before the transformation
well we can see that this is let's see
it's 5 units
tall and it is
7 units wide so this has an area of 35
square units pre-transformation so post
transformation we just multiply it by
the absolute value of the determinant to
get let's see 4 times
30 is 120 plus 4 times 5 is another 20
so this is going to get us to
140 square units and we're done